نحن الان في محيط جامعه الاقصى حيث تتواجد
اليات الاحتلال عشرات الامتار فقط عن هذا
المكان الذي نتواجد فيه الاليات في هذه
اللحظات تقوم بانشاء سوات الرمليه وكذلك
تقيم حواجز لحركه المواطنين وعمليات تفتيش
المواطنين النازحين الذين كانوا يتواجدون
داخل مدارس الاواء سواء في معسكر خانيونس
او حتى في منطقه حي الامل وكذلك في مقر
مركز تدريب الانرو في غرب محافظه خانيونس
اجبرت هؤ النازحين بالتحرك باتجاه هذا
الشارع وفي هذه اللحظات اطلاق نار كما
تستمعون بين الحين والاخر
لذلك الان اطلاق نار امر يحتاج الى اخذ
مزيد من الحيطه
والحذر اطلاق النار يعني متكرر
دائما مع حركه المواطنين والنازحين وهنا
خطوره شديده على المواطنين الذين يتحركون
باتجاه هذا الشارع من اجل تامين ذويه
الذين كانوا داخل مقرات ومراكز الاواء في
غرب محافظه خانيونس اليات الاحتلال
متواجده حتى هذه اللحظه في المنطقه وكما
استمعتم تطلق النار على المواطنين وضع
خطير على الطريق يهود اخذوا جوزي اخوه لا
اخذوه اخذوه معهم وين تشتتنا لا عارف
المراه ولا عارف الاولاد ولا عارف اخوي كل
واحد طلع من شقه خشت في
الدبابات اسحبها من مفترق الصناعه لعين
دوار الاقصى كله هذا دجيج كله دبابات ر
رتل من الدبابات والجيش وقفوك طيب وقفوك
الجنود وقفونا و وع بصمه العين كل واحد
بمر لا اكل لا شرب لا ملبس لا ماوى لا ولا
شي مى الحين ولا حاجه ولا حاجه منا ولا
حاجه ولا هينا قاعدين بدور مش عارف كيف
بدي الاقي مرتي انا
واخواتي و سوين اخواتي واخواتي وين بدي
الاقيه مش عارف كنا
تشتتنا سلم صار يطقو
علينا في س صير
فينا ايش تسوي لمين
الروح وين ما نروح نقول ح دينا خي نقعد
فيها يدونا عايشين يعني كنا في رعب امبارح
كنا كان يرموا فسفور
عليناه وقالوا لنا اخلوا يعني من كل جميع
الجهات الله